[Musique]
g d'émission le produit l importance qu
est ce que vous connaissez le bar autres
offres c'est son business et compagnie
oh je vois vraiment vieux dégueulasse ça
floride a été saboté le baron a demandé
une enquête discrète pour que ses
invités ne soient pas importunées vous
comprenez jean andreas ne peut pas
servir et si le plat
je vais les cuisiner un nain elle a été
basse jaillir d'elles mêmes méthodes
boula
boulot je suis la seule à genève à la
boj mais oui c'est bien moi je les vois
là bas que j'ai c'est de là bas
je soigne une chose avait dû tomber sur
un vieux rabbin sent pas moi abrous oui
je sens chez vous mais pas chez moi